radical republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene I've got to give
her credit she's trying to do something
clever she's trying to it it's totally
dishonest it's completely disgusting
it's also totally predictable but it is
clever which is she is trying to very
casually abandon the completely extreme
and delusional elements that she
previously associated with or still did
still does as far as we know including
the Q Anon stuff and the most extreme
elements of Maga and just sort of say ah
you know I kind of got sucked into stuff
but like I voted for Kevin McCarthy now
I'm in I'm part of the Republican
establishment and I'm going to be on
committees and it's all going to be
great and the reason she is doing this
is exactly what I just said she doesn't
want to be the extreme cartoon anymore
she wants to be taken seriously as a
Committee Member in good standing right
up there with Kevin McCarthy with the
speaker of the house and uh adjacent to
power
part of this rewriting of History
started in an interview on Fox News over
the weekend where when Howard Kurtz asks
her about some of her previous you know
associations affiliations Etc she
basically just writes it off and says oh
you know I got sucked into some stuff on
the internet yeah and just to deal with
one bit of History the Democrats
stripped you of your community
assignments after you reacted that was
raw politics but In fairness didn't you
also say around that period that you had
been a follower of Q Anon conspiracy
theories and you had rethought this and
you were no longer uh influenced by the
group well like a lot of people today I
had easily gotten sucked into some
things I'd seen on the internet but that
was dealt with quickly early on I never
campaigned on those things that was not
something I believed in that's not what
I ran for congress on so those are so
far in the past
um you tweeted this is a bold-faced
attempt or a bald-face attempt I go with
both I like both
um to try to excuse
and eliminate and remove her record
which includes she said crazy
anti-semitic things
um she was arguing that the Trump Riders
from January 6 should just be released
at their political prisoners that they
are they're Martyrs of some kind
um she taunted a kid who was traumatized
by gun violence
she went to an event
organized by and at which white
supremacist Nick Fuentes spoke and then
said I don't know anything about it she
accused Nancy Pelosi of trees and Jewish
space lasers on and on and on and on
and now she wants to go ah I saw some
stuff on the internet a lot of people
well it happens to a lot of people but I
didn't run on that stuff I didn't run on
that stuff the reason she's doing it is
that now that they're in power she needs
a different image support the speaker
get onto committees be taken seriously
as a States woman of some kind the
problem is you shouldn't be able to and
hopefully she won't be able to just
write off an entire swaths of her
history another clip I'm going to play
for you
um Howard Kurtz says you know a lot of
the people backing McCarthy didn't want
to certify the election is that still
important to the base and she goes
absolutely election denialism she says
is now mainstream Republican party when
things got heated you said this about
congressmanship Roy of Texas he refused
to object on January 6. that's not what
our base wanted so a lot of the people
who were back in Kevin McCarthy also
didn't vote to certify the Electoral
College results for Joe Biden do you
think that's an important thing to the
base even today oh it's it's very
important what I was pointing out is the
same people that conservatives were
holding up in high esteem don't
necessarily have those voting records
while they're at the same time
criticizing Kevin McCarthy who does
Kevin McCarthy did object on January 6
and he's been a top Target of the
Democrats and the January 6th committee
I believe that Joe Biden is a
legitimately elected president of course
Joe Biden's the president that's always
a silly question okay well he's trying
to be silly I was trying to well she
didn't answer the question the question
was is he a legitimately elected
president and she says of course he's
the president so even though she is
trying really hard to distance from q
and on and distance from the conspiracy
theories and whatever when it came down
to it right there she answered about
Biden being a legitimate president the
way they love doing it which is by
saying he is the president which is a
total cop-out and she insists that now
election denialism is part of the base
of the Republican party is it a big
enough base for them to win in 24 we
don't know okay one more clip from this
completely deranged interview uh she
says that a lot of the holdouts from the
speaker vote just wanted attention which
when I think of Congress people who want
attention my mind first goes to Marjorie
Taylor green but now she says others
wanted attention most important thing
that every single member has is their
voting card there's only 222 Republicans
and we need 218 to pass anything that's
where the magic happens and so the big
fight that happened this week I think
that a lot of it was really unnecessary
and just a bunch of fanfare that helps
popularity on the internet but doesn't
produce results now we have a speaker
that we can produce results with and we
have to do that by coming together to
get 218. yeah that's where our power
lies and so with this rules package
let's be very real we've got a Biden
White House we have a
democrat-controlled senate and we got to
get to 218 to accomplish anything right
ultimately Washington it's about the
math they just wanted attention it was
because they wanted to get popular on
the internet which is the epitome of
Marjorie Taylor green so let's go back
to the beginning
it's dishonest it's absurd it's pathetic
what she's doing but it just might work
she really might be able to rewrite and
remake her image now that they are in
control and that's a very scary thing to
think about